(audience applauds)
(Ross laughs)
All right, it's time for "Drew's News,"
the only news program-
Help.
And a-one, two.
That thinks you're
already a winner.
There you are.
Thank you, Rossy.
You're welcome, you're welcome.
And with me is the two-time winner
of Best Co-pilot of the Year, Ross Matthews.
Thank you, it's just an honor to be nominated.
Hi, everybody. Hi.
And Zooming in from Hollywood,
our special Oscars edition, our dear friends and family,
the fantastic hosts of "Entertainment Tonight,"
Kevin Frazier and Nischelle Turner!
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Oh my God, look at them.
Hi!
Hi, guys!
Hi, family.
How y'all doing?
Hey.
Oh my gosh, look at you.
Smoke show.
I mean, first of all, cousin Drew and cousin Ross-
Well, they did it right.
Came to the party, right?
Didn't hey do it right?
They always do.
(Nischelle laughs)
Oh, this old thing? (laughs)
You know, I love you guys so much
and I so look forward to these amazing celebrations
that we have-
Same.
In honor of Oscars and Emmys,
and I gotta start with the Holy Trinity, who are hosting.
Hmm, yes.
Yeah!
Wanda, Regina, Amy.
How do you guys feel about that triple threat?
Yeah.
Yes, indeed.
Drew, you were just talking about the fact
that you just had Amy on your show
and she was telling you kind of what's been going on
as far as rehearsals or whatnot,
and we just spoke to her a little bit ago as well,
and one thing she said that I loved so much,
that just gave me girl power to the extreme,
she mentioned that when they first got together
and were talking about what they were gonna do,
some of the producers or writers wanted them
to do some jokes that kind of pitted them against each other
or showed them in a competitive light.
And she said all three of them said, "No, absolutely not.
"We're getting up there with a sisterhood,
"we're gonna celebrate
"and it's going to be an amazing night."
I cannot wait for these three ladies
to take that stage and wreck it.
I'm ready. Let's bring it.
Let's bring it.
Well, speaking of winners,
do you wanna talk about some of the nominees?
Yes.
All right.
Ooh, yeah.
Let's get right into it.
Let's start with the biggie, Best Picture of the Year,
and here at the nominees.
All right, Kevin and Nischelle, who is gonna win this?
Dying to hear what you think.
Okay, I'm gonna take this one first.
I'm going with my heart on this, not with my head,
just so y'all know.
Yes.
And I loved "West Side Story" so, so, so much.
I love a musical, Steven Spielberg was amazing,
Ariana DeBose is like the darling of this awards season,
and I just feel like Oscar voters
will love this film so much as well.
Hmm.
Okay. That's interesting.
I would not be upset by that.
No, you would not.
Steven Spielberg was kind enough,
and we had just watched the opening trailer
of his latest film in Westwood
because he needed to do his research
and make sure the trailer was playing well,
and then the movie "Footloose" started.
And I was like, "(gasps) This looks so fun!"
And he was like, "No, no, we're going home."
And I was like, "(scoffs) Why?"
I was like, I don't know, eight, nine.
Oh really?
And he was like, "We're going home.
"I'm showing you 'West Side Story.'"
Oh.
"And that's the film
"I wanna teach you about tonight."
And so this is very personal for me.
Yeah, yeah.
So I would love, poetically, to see that film and him win,
and funny enough, my heart is also with some "CODA" action.
I do really love that film.
Me too.
It's a beautiful movie.
And Rossy and Kevin,
head and heart, what do you want to win?
Well, my heart is with "CODA"
'cause it's the movie that made me cry this year.
If you haven't seen it, it's an Apple film,
and it really, it's so beautiful.
But my head is thinking "Power of the Dog" is going to win
because it won the Golden Globe,
it's won all the critics' awards.
(audience applauds)
And it would be the first Netflix film to win Best Picture.
Kevin, thoughts.
You know what, I loved this year,
and I go with my heart too.
I loved "King Richard."
I know you did.
Oh, yeah.
And this is because I'm a sports guy
who has covered Venus and Serena
and watched their entire rise
and so this movie to me was special and different.
I thought Will was brilliant.
Now, I don't think that it will win either.
I do think that "Power of the Dog" will win,
but my heart is with "King Richard"
and I would not be sad if "West Side Story"
or "CODA" won either.
Yeah.
And if "CODA" were to win, a little fun fact there,
it would be the first film in 87 years
that wasn't nominated for either Best Director
or Best Editing-
Yes, yes.
To win, so that would be really interesting.
If that did, it would make history in that fact.
And this year does seem like it's prime for an upset,
so knows who's gonna win.
But we did ask our viewers to weigh in on Best Picture.
You wanna see the results?
Here they are.
They picked "West Side Story."
Come on, viewers!
Yes, viewers!
Yes! Yes!
With "Dune" close behind.
Wow.
Now, you know-
It was close.
Kevin and Nischelle,
oh, 'cause we've also done the Grammys together.
Yeah, right?
Yes.
And we gotta do that this year.
Our audience, I have to say,
has been 90% of the time correct.
Right. Yeah.
Their finger's on the pulse.
Come on, audience.
It's shocking.
Our audience is on point.
All right, we gotta talk the newest Oscar category.
This one has my heart
like nobody's business!
I love it!
So Fan Favorite.
Boy, thank you to the Academy for bringing this up.
It's the first time ever in history,
I don't think it will be the last.
It's a full write-in category.
Fans get to vote for any movie.
What do you think the fans are gonna do this year, guys?
There's no other film to pick
other than "Spider-Man: No Way Home."
I knew you'd go there.
I agree!
(Nischelle laughs)
Yeah.
That's what they say.
Okay, so our audience voted
and let's see what led the pack.
Yep, Spider-Man with 73%.
No surprise there.
(lively music)
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪